You are
always in the spotlight, and yet you care
most about people
who are never in the spotlight.
You care
most about people
that we as as a society have thrown away.
And I wonder why that is.
I think experience,
maybe just life
experiences, positive or negative.
Becoming a mom,
you know, life changes you.
I you know,
I think you get to a point where you
have experiences that just change you.
And when I met Alice
and I felt like it was a fairly
easy experience for me
when I know it shouldn't be to help
get someone out.
It takes ten, 20 years
to do what I did in six months.
And I didn't realize
the fight at that time.
To me, that was a few phone calls,
and that really struck me
that, you know, however it was done,
it was done.
I'm so grateful.
But like that that the system,
that process has to change.
I think you're selling
yourself short, though,
because Van Jones,
one of your biggest cheerleaders,
good friend of ours at CNN,
told me this about you.
There is nobody like Kim.
She is in a category of her own.
She takes every case
so seriously,
she'll have read the file
with more care than the attorneys.
She will know the case backwards
and forwards in every meeting.
Do you think this will be your life's
most meaningful work ahead?
I hope so.
I always joke with my mom,
who's my manager.
I say Kim K is retiring
and I'm just going to be an attorney.
Kim, Esquire. Yes.
So I was like,
so you can go help my siblings.
Are you.
So you can still have like,
what about my 10% or
so? I'm giving her the heads up.
Are you
would you ever consider a life
without the cameras?
Yeah, absolutely.
I do feel like I have a
there's a lot
that's always on TV and a lot
that's always out there.
But I think my friends
and my family know we really cherish
a lot of our private times and
I would be just as happy
being an attorney full time
and doing that.
The journey just really opened up my eyes
to so much that I just
it gets overwhelming
because there's so much to be done.
And I just,
you know,
I brought my sister Chloe to a prison
for the first time last week,
and that was really eye opening for her.
And I just
I would
totally spend more time doing that.
Cameras. No cameras.